看看他有没有贡献在前头，
要有这个贡献在前头的话，
他以后如果说能够安分守己的过日子，
咱就过日子，
如果他以后还在外面搞三搞四的是吧，
那咱就做个合伙人，
我们就一起养孩子，
你出钱我出力，
你说你20年生了二胎，
然后又发现她在外面有人了，
是不是对，
当时呢，
我是带着两个孩子，
因为我还有一个大的顾不过来和我婆婆带着两个孩子，
带着河南老家生活，
她当时是在西安工作，
有一天早晨我在给孩子吃完早饭之后，
突然就是2+1的哥哥打电话找到我，
就是说是我老公强迫他妹妹叫我给他100个，
我说我没有礼，
我说你们报帽子了，
后来呢，
报了帽子，
经过调查，
他们两个是自愿的，
然后我老公就被放出来了，
他后来回到河南老家了，
我看到他被打的鼻青脸肿的，
那个时候我就想和他分开，
我觉得没意思了，
不想和他过了，
后来我妈妈和家里人都劝说我，
说我两个孩子呢，
以后这孩子怎么办？
考虑再三，
我后后来还是选择了原谅，
因为我一个人养不了两个孩子，
我又舍不得把两个孩子分开，
在2022年的时候呢，
我女儿要读小学了，
我就带着孩子来到了她爸爸工作的地方，
当时是教育局给分配的，
与外来务工人员统筹进了一所一般的小学了，
其实我当时是想让孩子上一个好一点的学校，
但是。
是我们当时没有购房资质，
手里也没有那么多钱，
也没有依赖，
再后来2023年的时候，
我老公他突然想换车，
因为他当时是有车的，
他开了一辆10个左右的车，
非要买一辆50个的车，
我就不想让他换，
因为当时手里存款也就只有50个，
如果全部拿去买车的话，
我觉得我没有安全感，
我也怕他开个房点车出去之后呢，
就有别的女生会找他，
我就不想让他买，
隔三差五的，
就是说他要买车，
我就想把这个钱拿去给你买车，
还不如把房子给买了，
因为当时是租房子住的，
呃，
来西安也七八年了，
我们一直在租房，
想给孩子一个稳定的生活环境，
同时呢，
也让我那个二宝以后能读一个稍微好一点的学校，
在24年上半年的时候呢，
我们就把房子买了，
把我和孩子的户口都迁到陕西西安来了，
我考虑到孩子如果以后高考的话，
在西安这边会比河南有优势，
后来买了房子，
一年半的时间了，
这个房子就跌了，
只能40个首付快变没了。
我现在就很焦虑，
不知道该怎么办，
总是想如果当时没买房就好了，
辛辛苦苦攒下的钱就这样没了，
吃不好也睡不好，
如果现在把房子卖了吧，
我又不甘心，
因为我二宝还要等一年多之后呢才要读小学，
房卖了，
我儿子就读不了最口的小学了，
如果不卖就是我。
这些房子它会必须下跌，
因为但这的人口呢，
也越来越少，
我买了又是个学区房，
怕以后会跌到姐妹，
我的房子也跌，
大家的房子都跌一样的，
但在这之前，
最终我老公还是买了一辆50万的车，
哪来的钱呀，
我们去买了房子之后，
后来手里又延出去，
他就又付了20个，
然后盖了30个，
把这个车给买了，
现在每年的收入吧，
有个50个左右，
要押两个娃，
除去车贷房贷，
一年也就送了10个左右，
但房子现在就是写的是我一个人的名，
然后我和孩子的户口在这里，
车子写的是我老公的名字，
我现在就很纠结，
我现在这个房子到底是留着还是出掉？
姐妹啊，
我跟你分享一下我的心态好不好，
我的房子也跌了，
哎呀，
我心里是怎么想的呢？
反正呢确实需要住，
我感觉我住在这儿呢，
身体也健健康康的，
事业上也算是比较顺利，
孩子也健健康康的，
我就是给自己一个玄学的说法，
就这房子问我他跌不跌的，
我不怪他，
因为我在这住，
住的身体健康，
住的高高兴兴的，
一家人吃饭高高兴兴的，
孩子在这里缠上也是健健康康的，
那这房子就挺好，
我就是这么安慰我自己的，
我跟你们讲，
姐妹们啊，
龙飞，
我跟你说，
我是这个世界上最会安慰我的人，
我分享给你我这个方案就是说，
虽然说你买这个房子是亏了。
但大家都亏，
所有人买房子，
现在啊，
90%以上的都亏，
大家都亏，
但是呢，
我这个房子我自己住的舒心啊，
四四康康的超能几净呢，
孩子在这里头成长健健康康的，
那这房子忘我就得这么小问题，
这日子才能往下过，
知不知道，
反正你现在也不卖，
是不是你现在孩子以后读书，
孩子在这个房子里面有他们的温馨的回忆，
孩子在这个房子里面有他们成长的痕迹，
价值千金，
对不对？
我房友也是说，
他说你不能单纯的只考虑他的商业价值了，
对，
就是这意思啊，
再加上你们两口子一年还能挣50万，
姐妹啊，
咱俩掏心窝子的钱，
现在两口子能挣50万的家庭，
那真的是凤毛麟角啊，
我那天还看到一个视频，
对不对？
我这个时候不该笑，
把我一天的工资给笑没了，
但是我是觉得他们两口子那个心态真的很搞笑，
他们两口子都是90后，
还生了个娃，
两口子就在床上拿着手机对着自己拍视频，
他们两口子说啥？
他说哎呀，
这马上要过年了，
我们两口子都失业了，
可咋整啊？
房贷要多少钱啊？
车贷要多少钱啊？
两口子都失业了，
这可咋整啊？
你们有看到过吗？
要么不是罗菲姐说非要嘲笑人家他们两口子，
人家自己那个心态就非常的洒脱，
我们在旁边看的人就都受感染了，
你说现在啊，
就这样的夫。
轻易抓一大把失业的欠债的，
你们两口子现在是吧，
一年还能挣50万，
还能还得起房贷，
还能还得起车贷，
还有一套房子住着，
他买了个50万的车，
那这是多好的日子，
挺好的日子了，
他自从每次找了2+1之后，
我就不相信他了，
就是在我心里，
我们两个就是大伙过日子，
我就是照顾我娃的保姆，
他就是这个家的成工，
就觉得过日子吧，
没有像以前那么有倍劲了，
现在唯一的就是能让我和他过下的理由就是把两个娃给看好，
那我问你一年挣50万是你挣的多还是她挣的多呀？
他是主要拿工资，
我们是合伙自己做了一点生弟和我的娘家，
小哥能觉得是你挣么多，
对不对，
对，
其实我是没有上班的，
我现在就看着两个娃，
以前的时候我是能额外再挣10个的，
就是在这个基础上我还能挣10个，
但自从那件事之后，
我就觉得没有费头了，
我也不想工作了，
就想着把我两个娃平平安安的长大，
我把我自己该做的义务给尽到。
你现在想要弄我的问题是啥呀？
就是我这种心态，
可以送给我几句话嘛，
以后的日子该怎么过？
我觉得是这样啊，
我给你分享一下我的感受好不好？
我现在的感受是，
比如说啊，
我老公他要是背叛我了哈，
他要是跟别的女的好了哈，
我是怎么看待这个问题的，
我跟大家今天讲点真心话。
就我就往前瞅一瞅，
比如说在我怀孕啊，
生孩子啊这个过程当中啊，
他有没有恩情在我前头，
我老公呢，
他是在我怀孕啊，
备孕啊，
生孩子这个阶段啊，
他给我做了好多顿饭，
他平时也是一个非常忙的人啊，
他能天天给我做饭，
我感觉这个恩情在这儿，
就算有一天她说她跟别人好了，
跟别人说到了，
我感觉我俩也不至于说你死我活，
不至于说就非常仇恨啊，
就干嘛干嘛的，
所以呢，
就换到你身上，
咱们先看一下这个老公对家庭有没有什么贡献啊，
包括对孩子呀，
对你在怀孕生孩子这个过程当中，
给你产检了吗？
哎呀，
对心疼过你吗？
对你好不好呀，
就是看看他有没有贡献在前头，
要有这个贡献在前头的话，
他以后如果说能够安分守己的过日子，
咱就过日子，
如果他以后还在外面搞三搞四的是吧，
那咱就做个合伙人，
我们就一起养孩子，
你出钱我出力，
我俩一起把这孩子养好，
咱也不至于说你死我活，
不至于说非得对吧，
把他弄到家破人亡，
非得把他弄到净身出户，
非得把他弄到这个名声搞臭了，
那没有这个必要，
我现在是真的是这种心态，
就是供你参考，
你就看看你老公带你养育这两个孩子，
生育这两个孩子的过程当中，
有没有什么恩义在前头，
对孩子的付出，
对孩子。
照顾她有没有什么，
存了一点儿亲情在前头，
呃，
自己又能挣钱，
娘家又这么给力，
孩子又这么健康，
把自己保饬的漂漂亮亮的，
干干净净的，
然后50岁一起去上个综艺，
谈个恋爱。
不，
我最近看到了个综艺，
就是50岁以上的姐姐哥哥在那谈恋爱，
搞对象，
就是有了这个奔头，
我来我对吧？
嗯，
好，
就这样啊，
拜拜啊，
我现在都已经开始幻想了，
我要上综艺，
我要去谈恋爱，
后来50岁了之后，
我要去上个综艺，
我要去谈个恋爱，
幻想一下，
先给自己有一个奋斗的目标，
有一个奔斗，
上链宗，
50岁谈恋爱，
我应该很松弛了，
都是剧本的姐姐，
那我不管，
我也去找个剧本，
我跟你说那天谁来着？
兰江律师不是来我直播间刷了一个礼物吗？
不是有姐妹就是开兰江律师和我的玩笑吗？
虽然我嘴上说哎呀姐都多大年纪了还开这种玩笑，
但我心里想是开多开点，
谁能懂我这个点，
以后干凡事她长得帅的男生来我直播间了，
你姐妹没随便开啊？
我嘴上肯定说，
哎呀姐都要跳广场舞了，
姐都业多大年纪了还开这种玩笑，
但我心里说不开点，
长得越帅看的越多，
回头把这一段剪出来啊，
千万不能发个兰张越是看我这姐妹之间吧啊，
私房话不要到外面去乱说。
不要到外面去瞎说好吗？
记得点赞关注哦。